[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode dans
corps vous l'émission dans laquelle je
reçois tous les clichés du cinéma mais
en chair et en os mon invité
d'aujourd'hui est une victime dans tous
les sens du terme la part est à peine il
disparaît déjà je reçois le personnage
qui meurt en premier dans les films
d'horreur
[Musique]
personnage qui meurt en premier dans les
films d'horreur bonjour bonjour
attention à l'herbe ou non pardon je
plaisante on n'a pas invité le meurtre
et qui se cacher sa victime on n'est pas
comme ça savez moi j'ai l'habitude d'un
selon moi qui me fais couper la tête dès
la première scène du film donc c'est
terrible quand même ce que vous subissez
à savaria pas mort d'homme
c'est comme ça je suis habitué et le
fait que ce soit quand même toujours
vous systématiquement c'est dégueulasse
non vous êtes révolté pas écouté un vrai
je suis pas hyper prudent non plus quoi
par exemple des fois je sais que mes
trois potes caucasiens ont fait une
balade une parka 3 d'un côté moi tout
seul de l'autre je marche marche et bim
ares qu'en plus je suis persuadé que si
votre personnage survivent et on
pourrait prend le temps de vous
connaître qui sait vous avez peut-être
une personnalité de l'humour un merci
c'est gentil mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est pas de chance
quoi non mais le fait que ce soit
toujours vous pourriez vous me voyez pas
le japon son carnet défend la pièce
maintenant à regarder bas on a permis d
non plus voyez pas le souci quand même
voici un truc dit le nom je me
permettrai pas c'est et je vois voulait
revenir mais c'est pas à moi de mai il
ya quoi et je pense que vous savez
peut-être mais je peux pas l'admettre et
bah si si si c'est le lieu c'est
l'endroit c'est le moment c'est aussi ça
encore vous cédez scoop on va le faire
ensemble ça vous dérange pas vous êtes
le personnage qui meurt en premier dans
les films d'horreur parce que parce que
vous êtes noir timide rebond timide
j'ai convenant d'un truc attention non
le cinéma ne voit pas la couleur un je
sais maintenant que je connais le
problème qui est donc ma timidité je
peux ne plus mourir en premier par
exemple il faudrait dire non toi vas
voir dans la grange des bruits qu'on
entend au bout de 4 minutes de film
c'est super ça mais oui il faut le dire
si vous voyez un tueur la prochaine fois
vous avec un couteau avec un couteau
vous détournez que je détourne le tôt le
regard aussi le regard aussi c'est super
d'initiatives pour être le mec il meurt
pas du tout ouais après c'est un film
d'horreur ou alors je pourrais être le
mec qui ce sera la fin non quand même
pas puis c'est le jeune fille
ensanglantée les quelques pluies désolé
l'attendait au niveau de la
représentation des timides j'ai
l'impression que ça avance quand même ah
oui pour le coup ça oui par exemple moi
mes ancêtres à l'époque qui je n'aime
pas dans le film commence à ben il
s'était jouée par des gens qui étaient
non timide oui ou alors je pourrais être
le tueur ou la wii
je suis désolé on va devoir la
télévision parce que pour le coup c'est
un petit peu raciste que vous venez de
dire monsieur la highway non non non non
y'a pas de mal mais non pas là pendant
la pause et juste après on se retrouve
dans encore vous avec le personnage doué
en informatique qui s'avère à 13 éthique
par hasard
mais après les maths aussi c'est leur
truc aux gens aux gens doués en
informatique un oui ça peut me faites
pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit parce que
tu es pour savourer toujours un premier
temps border quand même
[Musique]
et avant de mourir tu as le temps de
voir qui c'est le tueur ouais ouais je
sais que s'annonce un pote qui se
vengent parce qu'il est jaloux depuis
traîne avec nous tu vois moi j'ai que
c'est lui mais je ne peux pas lui dire
tu sais pas pourquoi
vous les timides